how hard has that been to get sober i
mean to stay sober how difficult is it
on a scale of one to ten ten being like
it's ridiculously hard i'll tell you the
truth it depends right at the beginning
it's very very hard that's ten okay you
start off because you're in the habit of
doing this whatever it is and you know
compulsive behavior it's like if you
limit alcohol or alcohol and drugs it's
a sort of certain segment of society if
you look at the people that overeat eat
their [ __ ] feelings and end up just
as unhealthy it's a lot more if you look
at people who shop and gamble or have
sex or relationships or use the [ __ ]
phone we're we're very programmed to
seek out rewards and get compulsive
about it gamble whatever
um nonetheless it's [ __ ] hard because
you've taught yourself this is the only
way to ease my pain i'm in pain this
thing will make it better
and i used to go to meetings and hear
all these like old-timers say
i'm a grateful alcoholic and you know
the obsession left me a long time ago
and i would get so angry you know i'd be
like [ __ ] you you're not grateful what
are you grateful for you [ __ ] your
life up you're grateful congratulations
boy i want some of that too and you the
obsession left you the [ __ ] are you
doing here you don't want to drink you
know no call get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm dealing with problems i want to have
a drink how about that you know you're
you're just
and i resented that for a long time and
i went through a series of you know i
got so wrestled for a year year and a
half i wanted to be so right committed
to it and the problem with that fight is
like you can win a thousand times you
know you only have to give him once and
you can you're never gonna win all the
time right so
something fundamental has to change and
i hate to say it but the cure for
addiction the only cure i've seen and
not like these [ __ ] overpriced rehabs
or a lot of these fraudulent fixes that
are sold to people
they're they're good people who will
support you alcoholics anonymous i think
by and large is a good organization it's
not the only one
the cure for addiction is suffering
you suffer enough
that something inside you goes i'm done
and i'm lucky because i hit that point
before i lost
really the things that were the most
important was not my career or money
always my relationship with my kids and
when i felt as if
it impacted them
i recognized it
it was the worst day of my life
i made amends
and i for a while i thought maybe this
is temporary this feeling is going to go
away
but since that day i swear to christ
i have not
ever wanted to drink once
wow so it's the easiest thing in the
world because every time you think about
it i'm just like holy [ __ ] that's the
worst exactly in the world i don't want
that i can't do that and that's the
piece that people find so now i'm that
[ __ ] who's like you know i'm grateful
i learned a lot i actually got to be a
better person through this process and
i've lost the obsession